what's up gamers it's time for twitchcon
2018 epic cringe compilation I got a
couple hopes I got a couple of guesses I
think there's gonna be there's gonna be
dabbing what did I teach you the micro
dab guys come on Michael yes yes you yes
beautiful I think there's gonna be some
pretty lit fortnight dances but most
importantly there's going to be I think
of myself as like above the average
person I think of myself as like above
the average person no good way to say
this I think of myself as like above the
average person so I don't feel like many
people could relate to me how do you
guys are gamers so I got something
special for you the elgato hd60 is this
baby lets you capture in 1080p 60 frames
per second what else do you want baby oh
oh irony aside I I'm ever using a legato
since the beginning of my youtube career
they're always on the top and I'm proud
to have them as a sponsor I'm even more
proud because now I have my very own
design
thank you have got oh very cool honestly
that is pretty epic so basically you can
plug this into your Xbox or Playstation
I you can use it to record with your
phone iPad all these kinds of things
it's the best way to do it I guarantee
you if you're looking for a way to
record video or a gameplay footage
check out the elgato 60s thank you very
cool let's go on for the video first of
all I really enjoyed the the ninja
roasts you know a lot of the people here
that are here in front of us are our
viewers which is what actually amazes me
about Utama that you're up here because
most your viewers are outside because of
the age restriction
[Laughter]
[Applause]
damn that was a sick roast how the
audience just apparently it's the
greatest thing yet no one's ever heard I
don't know why the audience Street like
yeah it was a it was a roast okay I'm
not gonna deny that it was a roast and I
appreciate it but the audience reaction
is just so mismatched this guy oh my god
this audience are dicks try out
apparently one competition that was
pretty epic thank you everybody for
coming out today this was amazing we're
so excited to have everybody and what an
amazing tournament from you guys so on
behalf of the Doritos brand we are proud
to present the Doritos Bowl trophy to
team shroud let's give it up for team
shroud I don't know why this is so funny
the Dorito Bowl champion combined with
this music that's an epic moment I can
only imagine putting countless hours
into video games for this moment to get
the Dorito volge
championship
I always wonder you know who's watching
these streams but things start to make
sense when you watch these conventions a
lot of things make sense what a
gentleman you know then put his slob on
her back why bother with the hand if
you're not even gonna you know I don't
get it
how does you know I'm the most awkward
handshake person in the world but you'll
that catch me dead before I use a hand
hover I don't get it you can't mess that
up at least how do you mess that up it's
literally impossible I get it you know
it's just kids dancing it's fine
you can't really go all right so Creech
everyone stains as a kid and it's been a
peak wrench but the thing I don't
understand is why are they people
watching it look at that why are there
literally hundreds of people watching
and then this Stan shows up the god of a
fortnight dance shows up look at that
child everybody please give it up for
the for tonight's dance crew make some
noise
I just realized that we have this a
similar name
[Music]
do they just forget to go on stage are
there there okay
[Music]
so confuse everything
this confuses me I feel so old why do I
feel so old I don't want to be like this
guys please someone saved me make me
enjoy things again fortnight everything
is just killing me okay
I feel like knowing the fortnight dams
at this point is the equivalent of
knowing how to knowing how to breathe
apparently every kid ever has just
studied in front of the mirror how to do
the dance you know that anyone that
knows the fortnight dance deliberately
took time to watch up go to online to
watch a fortnight dance tutorial to make
sure that they can follow the movement
so that they can do the dance as well
but unless you know this dance don't
even talk to me okay
[Music]
I'm not sure if this is twitch calm but
it's a beautiful clip grab this black
monster right here that's right only why
we close out I'm gonna have a you hear
that cracking open a cold one Duncan you
got a problem do you like the test of
that black monster let's just go to the
game this is what does happen there no
hug thank you very much this is me at
any convention okay
no physical contact we talked about this
I don't want to end up in a cringe
compilation okay no hugs no nothing this
guy knows what's up and I can respect
that dammit you just dodged a bullet
right there very easy I mean why would
you hug if you're on camera what an
idiot get new friends that guy what if
you guys didn't know his actual first
name is dick which it must be tough
being named after your favorite
celebrity body part that go after to
gain popularity Drake marshmallow Mark
Cuban who's next
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean I only lag like at a few spots
yeah I do you want my backpack you'll
have to come to my room to get it though
I think it's a win-win but you know what
joke I think it's a way way I guess I'd
die a joke hey listen joke time I think
poco laws you gave me like a little clip
yeah put the wrong video I don't know
what this is I'm so sorry I'm really
I've never seen that video before that
was such an epic you know and these
people don't even know the end that no
me doesn't mean when I try and make fun
of people and they don't understand and
then this is unfunny and uncomfortable
yeah no one knows how to react
that was cool I guess Halloween oh yeah
I'm good not too good no bread no that's
how you know your life you're sober if
you ever get genome it's time to pack
your baggage say goodbye you might as
well start digging Your Grave it's over
then of course we get to that the
greatest cliff of all time the man that
decided to summarize the mind of every
twitch streamer on this platform let's
just jump into it don't feel like many
of my viewers should relate themselves
to me because and this is like super
like kind of like
like God like kind of weird is like I do
think of myself as better than or not
better but like bigger that's a good way
to say this I think of myself as like
above the average person so I don't feel
like many people could relate to me as
like bad as that sounds I know but like
that's just genuinely hi lord have mercy
on your soul I think that what makes
this clip so great is that he knows he's
not supposed to say it he's like it's
really no good way to say this but
basically God I'm basically better than
everyone else
Loki like god complex just stop right
there if you're ever in that moment
don't cross the border I mean I
shouldn't be talking about this at all
actually remember mine I just love how
you know you're a streamer you're the
kind of person that relies on donations
from other people you're basically
begging other people for money and
that's how you make a living but you're
so better than the average person you're
still like you're still above the
average person I'm gonna go on a limb
and say no no you're not you're 100% not
better than the average person and
anyone that think they're better than
the average person is 100% not better
than the average person if he just said
it as a meme instead of hesitating and
be like you know what I just think I'm
better than they have a refreshing I
don't think anyone would care but the
fact that he was sort of Hester saying
be like oh this is kind of weird there's
no good way to say this but yeah I'm
better I'm better now this has been
twitch con 2018 epic cringe moment I
hope you gamers enjoyed it if you did
Penn Stater smashing like and
subscribing we're trying to hit 69
million subscribers for 40 series can we
make it happen guys and yeah just you
know what to do and as always good bye
[Music]